hey what is up everybody it's animac
here for anime outproar and the mha
finale continues to get darker and
darker and in more ways than one the
idealistic hero story that we used to
know is completely gone the final Arc is
getting more and more intense and the
pressure of such a Monumental Arc may be
getting to horikoshi so let's talk about
it you guys know how this works if you
enjoy my mha content and you'd like to
see more in the future leave a quick
like and comment right now it helps me
out with that YouTube algorithm and if
you watch my videos regularly but you
haven't taken the time to subscribe yet
do me a big favor and make this the
video you subscribe and hit that
notification Bell to turn on all
notifications finally this video will of
course contain mha manga spoilers so
please proceed with caution you have
been warned in the previous chapter we
saw that all the todorokis are now
finally going to be together in one
place but it is not a happy reunion
Dobby is on the verge of killing himself
in a massive thermal explosion and if
this explosion go goes off Dobby's
entire family will be killed right along
with him not to mention the thousands of
other people within a five kilometer
radius of Dobby's current location and
the more this final Todoroki Showdown
progresses the more likely it seems that
someone's death is inevitable as I said
in my last video the most likely
scenarios are that either just Dobby
dies or Dobby and then never die but the
other todorokis survive I think the
latest chapter basically confirms my
prediction but let's start at the
beginning as the new chapter gets going
we see that eda's engines have
completely crumbled he pushed himself
beyond plus Ultra in order to get shot
at the gunga as soon as possible and
although he succeeded in all credit to
him there is a physical price that he
must pay for over exerting himself so
much this is as far as Ida can go and
that is when Shoto takes over he uses
Flashfire fist phosphor to propel the
icejet forward balancing both heat and
eye ice in order to reach speeds that
break the sound barrier essentially
Shoto Anita in their makeshift ice plane
are now moving as quickly as a modern
fighter jet this is a fact that's easy
to just scroll by while you're reading
the chapter but it's pretty insane when
you think about it tsukauchi is watching
Shoto Anita's approach and he remembers
how all might specifically told him that
two quirks would be crucial for averting
disaster at Goomba half hot half cold
and engine tukauchi acknowledges that
all might has become a truly diligent
teacher and that he really knows his
students including their character and
their most important strengths as Ida
and Shoto finally arrive at gunga Shoto
leaves eat on the ground and proceeds
towards Dhabi on his own Ida tells Shoto
that thanks to him he finally became the
person that he had always wanted to be
and Ida tells Shoto that it's now time
for him to do the same as Shoto rushes
towards Dobby in the fiery Battlefield
we get a brief flashback fact that
reveals what Shoto has been telling his
mother in the letters that he had sent
her during her stay in that mental
institution we see Shoto telling his
mother that he is trying to reach the
level of his classmates which might
surprise you at first because Shoto has
always been one of the strongest
students with one of the most powerful
quirks but then we realize that Shoto
isn't talking about strength Shoto is
strong but he struggles with other
things that most of his classmates don't
have a problem with things like
socializing and being friends and just
talking to each other Shoto is trying to
have conversations with his classmates
every day and even though sometimes
these conversations lead to arguments in
the end these arguments help them all to
understand each other better sometimes
his friends and classmates get angry and
even cry and sometimes it's not even
about something that happened to them
but they are crying for the sake of
others this is what Shoto aspires to and
even though he knows that it will be
difficult he vows to do his best again
it might seem odd at first that Shoto is
so concerned with such basic thing
things like having conversations and
understanding his classmates and forming
friendships and having basic empathy but
we can't forget how he was raised at a
very young age his father isolated him
from everyone including his own siblings
and raised him to be the strongest hero
at all costs Shoto had plenty of
physical training and battle practice as
a kid but he didn't have any practice
with socializing making friends and
feeling empathy for others Shoto
recognizes that this is his weakness and
he is doing his best to improve in these
areas areas that for many of us just
come completely naturally this is a
clear reminder of what a difficult
childhood Shoto had and how much he
missed out on in exchange for becoming
as strong as he is and after everything
he went through and after his father
raised him to Value strength above all
other things I think it's incredible
that Shoto didn't become an egomaniac
obsessed with power instead he is
actively trying to relate to others and
to have empathy and to form friendships
he doesn't think that he's better than
his classmates in fact he realizes that
in many ways they are better than him
and he needs to catch up this truly
speaks to shoto's impeccable character
no amount of trauma can corrupt him and
turn him into a bad person because he's
such a good person then finally Shoto
arrives on the battlefield where it
looks like Dobby is literally just about
to explode and take Endeavor and
everyone else out with him Shoto calls
out to his brother and in that moment
Shoto is both the fierce hero student he
is now and the small kid who just wants
his big brother to acknowledge Him Shoto
still has so many things to say and to
get off his chest both to his brother
and to everyone else but first he has to
prevent this horrible explosion from
happening and so Shoto unleashes his
ultimate attack great glacial age year
this is a move that shot already used on
Dobby once and this time it seems to be
even more powerful than before 4.
basically Shoto builds up both his ice
and fire powers to their absolute
maximum using flash fire fist phosphor
and then he rushes at his opponent and
smashes them with a huge wave of cold
fire that covers everything around it in
ice when he used this on Dobby and
kamino he was able to extinguish his
Flames at least temporarily and this
time the attack looks even stronger this
time it doesn't look like a huge wave of
cold fire it looks like a cold fire
explosion that consumes everything
around it thanks to the reporters
filming from the air everyone watches
live at shoto's Cold fire bomb goes off
and the world is stunned when the dust
clears or I guess I should say when the
icy fog clears Shoto is still standing
tabian Endeavor are both lying on the
ground barely conscious with the other
todorokis sitting close by Rey fuumi and
Natsu are injured but clearly alive and
conscious Dobby's fire has seemingly
been extinguished and the thermal
explosion he almost caused has been
averted a clearly exhausted Shoto says
that on his own his great glacial Ager
would not have been able to do this
Dobby's Flames were even hotter now than
they were at kamino but this time Shoto
had the help of his mother sister and
brother Natsu who were all using their
own powerful ice quirks to back up his
ice Quirk attack Shoto says that on his
own he would not have been able to match
Dobby's Firepower so maybe he's not such
a masterpiece after all maybe Dobby was
always stronger than Shoto maybe Dobby
was always the Masterpiece after all he
just wasn't aware of it meanwhile Dobby
seems to be on the verge of death like
seriously he looks like he's about to
die any second his body seems to be
seconds away from crumbling into literal
dust but he is still somehow able to
speak and he says that they should all
just die and perish especially Endeavor
but Endeavors still isn't giving up on
his son Toya he crawls up closer to Toya
and he apologizes once again he says he
is truly sorry for not going to Secreto
Peak that day but Dobby AKA Toya says
that he hates his dad and his entire
family and sever says that it's okay he
will listen to everything to everything
that Toya wants to say to him and never
also apologizes to Rey for pushing her
past her limit to fumi for putting
everything on her shoulders and to Natsu
for neglecting him finally he apologizes
to his youngest son Shoto for everything
that he did to him for everything that
his blind obsession with surpassing
almight made him do the final page
features toga looking in the direction
of the Todoroki family and wondering
whether Toya was able to smile in the
end this seems to imply that Toya really
is about to die or at least toga
believes that he is oh and I almost
missed this when I was reading the
chapter the first time but toga calls
him toyakun here she doesn't call him
Dobby this isn't something that I think
about often but the fact that toga calls
Dobby toyakun is pretty important she
has only ever known him as the villain
Dobby and Dobby himself kept saying how
Toya is dead and only Dobby exists now
and yet toga still feels that his true
identity is Toya not Dobby that's
definitely an interesting detail for me
but moving on the chapter ends as a
fierce looking ochako continues to fight
against toga and the ongoing Sad Man's
parade and so we are left with the
mystery of whether this really is the
end for Dobby and probably also Endeavor
or if something could still happen to
somehow save their lives I'll be honest
endeavor's apologies to each of his
family members individually definitely
seemed like a big death flag it almost
seemed like he was saying goodbye to all
of them individually before he
inevitably dies alongside Toya I mean
horikoshi could still flip the script
somehow and have Endeavor survive but
from what we've seen so far it
definitely seems like this is the end
for endeavor and of course in terms of
Toya the death flags are absolutely
everywhere he looks like he's barely
alive at this point so unless he has
some sort of super regeneration cheat
code hidden away somewhere this is
likely the end for him do you guys agree
with me that Toya and Endeavor are
likely going to die here or do you think
that one or maybe even both of them
could survive what would you want to
happen and what do you think would be
the best for the story don't get me
wrong I think Endeavor is an amazing
character overall the best written
character in mha but I kind of feel like
his story would be better and more
complete if he really did die here as he
finally atones for his sins agree
disagree let me know down below whatever
happens it's clear that Toya and
Endeavor are out of the war for good so
what does this mean for the other
battlefields we just saw toga again at
the end of the chapter so does this mean
that she's about to be taken off the
board as well and then it's just all for
one and shigaraki I mean the ark has to
end sometimes so maybe this is when The
Dominoes truly begin to fall and the
villains are defeated one by one this is
of course a Shonen so the heroes will
win in the end the only question is how
heavy is the price that the heroes will
ultimately have to pay for their Victory
finally as you might have noticed the
mha manga has taken several unplanned
sudden breaks recently and many are
speculating that this is related to
horikoshi's health personally I don't
have any insight info or anything but if
horikoshi really is having health issues
then he should absolutely prioritize his
hell like yeah we all love this series
and we can't wait to see what happens
next but at the end of the day this is
just a story and horikoshi is a real
person so he has to put his health first
we can wait if you guys enjoyed this
video and you want to see more mha
content in the future leave a quick like
and comment right now it helps me out a
lot and if you've gotten this far into
the video but you still haven't
subscribed do me a big favor and
subscribe right now and hit that
notification Bell to turn on all
notifications occasions you can also hit
me up on Twitter and Instagram at
animeoproar as always thank you guys so
much for watching and until next time
see ya Space Cowboys